THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME
TO HEARING OF OUR
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN IN HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS. SENATE HAS MADE
HAS MADE NECESSARY
TO NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR HOLDING
A COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND THERE ARE NO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY. ABOUT A PUBLIC
ACCESS. WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
OR RISK FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-692-8953. 877-692-8953 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO
FIVE SIX NINE OH NINE I'LL SAY
THAT AGAIN SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX
NINE. OH NINE. DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES THAT WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND-
COMMITTEE WEBSITES. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE AND ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THERE MAY BE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER. YOU'LL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE. THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE ON MUTED AND READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE GET NEW
YOUR PHONE COMMUTE THE DEVICE.
BEFORE YOU SPEAK. OBVIOUSLY I
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED IT'S ALSO A
GOOD TIME TO REMIND EVERYONE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY THAT THIS
IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE. SO
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE
BILL. YOUR TESTIFYING ON IN
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM REPEATING
PRIOR TESTIMONY. WE SHOULD NOT
BE RELATED GETTING THE MERITS
OF THE BILL WE SHOULD BE
FOCUSING ON THE FISCAL. OF
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW
USE OF ONLINE TOOLS. AND OUR
TECHNOLOGIES OBVIOUSLY
EVERYBODY PLEASE RE RESPECTFUL
AND OUR PATIENTS ON ALL PARTIES
IS APPRECIATED AND WE RESPOND
TO HEAR FROM EVERYONE. WE'VE
GOT FORTY TWO BILLS ON THE
AGENDA ONE OF WHICH IS ELIGIBLE
FOR DO PASS. THE REST OF THE
BILLS ARE SUSPENSE CANDIDATES.
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON
THE BILL OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GOING
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM I SEE WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO MISTER CHIEF.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS PORTANTINO PIERRE. AND-
BRING. SENT BRADFORD. BRADFORD
HERE SENATOR JONES HERE CENTER
JONES HERE SENATOR GRAHAM
AUGER. CENTER LAYERED HERE
EARLIER HERE CENTER MIKE
POUNCEY. WE HAVE FOUR MEMBERS
PRESENT WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
BUSINESS DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF THE
HEARING IN TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS. OF INSTITUTING A
TIME LIMIT ON WITNESS TESTIMONY
EACH SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED
THREE MINUTES OF TOTAL TIME FOR
PRIMARY TESTIMONY. ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY. MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. ON
THE MEASURE. IF NECESSARY WE
WILL ALSO LIMIT THIS ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY TO TWELVE MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE. AS A REMINDER ALL
MADE WITNESSES SHOULD LIMIT
THEIR TESTIMONY THE FISCAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL. I'M GOING
TO HEAR TO THE NAME
ORGANIZATIONS AND AFFILIATIONS.
POSITION WHICH COMMONLY CALLED
ME TO PART OF THE HEARING. I
WILL BE HERE TO THAT STRICTLY.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE RIGHT
TO OUR FIRST BILL WHICH IS AB
THREE MR FONG. EXHIBITION OF
SPEED ON HIGHWAY PUNISHMENTS.
IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAVE PRESENTATION. SO
MOVE TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. FOR ANYONE HERE
THERE'S NOBODY IN OUR ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE AS WE OPENED
THE PUBLIC COMMENT. THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE- WISHING. TO SUPPORT
AB THREE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND IF YOU WISH TO
SEE AT THE OF AB THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PUT YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE. THERE
ARE NOW. THANK YOU MESSAGE HERE
WE DO HAVE A FEW KEY WENT UP.
THE LINE NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. OF THE KERN COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE NUMBER
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SHARING INVOLVED IS
WHAT THE RUNNING PUBLIC POLICY
GROUP HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF BAKERSFIELD IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE THANK YOUNG. AND AT
THE TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NO MINIMUM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE OPPOSED. AB THREE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OF AB THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER AND TAKE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR- NOW. AT THIS TIME
OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE Q.
RIGHT HOLD ON ONE SECOND WE'RE
GONNA GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WE TAKE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT FINANCE
HAVE A FILE OF. YOUR THE
DEPARTMENT- THAT WE DON'T STILL
I'M NOT DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
ALSO. I DON'T LIVE CLOSE TO
THIS BILL I KNOW THE SCORE.
BECAUSE IT LOCAL NINE AND- THE
EXTENT UPDATES TO OUR LEGACY
WHO ARE NOT IN TIME FOR THE
ISSUE PART WELL LAST WEEK.
PROEHL CONTACT US WITH THE
SPELL BUT NO THIS CALL JACKSON
OF SPEED AND SPEAK ON THANK YOU.
YOUR CONNECTION IS NOT GREAT-
REPORTER FINANCING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THREE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON AB
TWENTY TWO BY MCCARTY
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN ROMAN
FUNDING THE NEXT ITEM IS AB
TWENTY TWO- AND THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
HEARING FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT.
OF AB TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO.
FIVE ONE ZERO. I WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY TWO
COULD PRESS ONE BUTTON THERE
ARE NOW. I ONE MOMENT MISTER WE
DO HAVE PEOPLE QUEUING UP.
THANK YOU IN. MY NUMBER THIRTY
THREE THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JONATHAN
HOWARD ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND
INSTRUCTS ACCORDED AB TWENTY
TWO THANK YOU. NUMBER THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHRISTOPHER MERICLE HEAD START
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OUR
GRANTEES AND ACCORDING TO ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SITE THE
ASSOCIATION IS REMOVING ITS
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY TWO. THANK
YOU. AND AT THE TIME OF THE
CHAIR BUT THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING OPPOSITION WILL OPEN IT
UP HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERETHERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. AB TWENTY TWO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TWO.
CONTRACTS ONE ZERO. AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH A LINE
NUMBER IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. AND AT THIS TIME
IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL COME
BACK TO THE FARM AND FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AT THIS
BILL CREATES ON GOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS IN THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BEGINNING
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ESTIMATES TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE GENERAL FUND COSTS
OF SEVEN POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. AND EIGHT POINT SIX
POSITIONS OF WHICH TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ANY
POSITIONS ARE I'M GOING. TO
EMPLOYMENT PROVISIONS OF THE
SPELL. ASSEMBLY WHILE THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND BE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES COMMISSION. I'M NOT
ESTIMATED THE LEVEL OF
RESOURCES NEEDED TO CONSULT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT. IMPACTS
WILL BE MINOR AND SEVERAL THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE HEARD FROM
FINANCE I SEE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY TWO
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
AB SEVEN FIVE NINE BY MCCARTY
ON ELECTIONS COUNTY OFFICES-
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION AND
WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. THE MINIMUM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN FIVE NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
FIVE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. IT WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN FIVE NINE.
PRESS ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW.
AT THE TIME OF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE TO YOU ALL RIGHT
REMOVED OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. CLOSE
TO SEVEN FIVE NINE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. AT SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN FIVE NINE. PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE INE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OF AB. SEVEN FIFTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN
THERE ARE NOW. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WE HAVE THE
NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION. AND
AT THE TIME OF THE DAY WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE CAN KILL ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
COME BACK COMPARTMENT FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS
BILL MAY CREATE STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE BECAUSE
REQUIRES A NEW PROGRAM OR
HIGHER LEVELS SERVICE RELATED
TO LOCAL ELECTION CYCLES THE
MAGNITUDE OF MANDATE EXPOSURE
IS UNKNOWN BUT COULD BE
SIGNIFICANT. ALAS THEY WOULD
KNOW THAT THE SECRETARY OF
STATE ESTIMATES NO COST THAT'S
RESULT IN THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT
HEARING FOR FINANCING-
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIS BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON AB TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN ON PEACE
OFFICERS USE OF FORCE IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATIONS. WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S
NOBODY HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE THIS COMING AROUND
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU MEDICARE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX. POINT FIVE ONE
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH A LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE BACK IN THE QUEUE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH T SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE BELIEVE THEIR
OWN NOW. WE DO HAVE PARTY TO
JOIN UP WITH THE CHAIR. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
PANEL AGAINST REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND WE'RE HONORED TO
SUPPORT AB. TWENTY SIX. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE YOUR IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
WILLIAM UP IN BURKE ON BEHALF
OF THE BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU YEAH WE
DO HAVE SOMEONE ELSE DO NOT ONE
MOMENT. MY NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING DON THANKS
FOR EVERYTHING A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX THANK
YOU. AND AT THE TIME OF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IS HAVING TWENTY
FORTY. FIGHTERS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB
TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. RIGHT WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE A LINE NUMBER IN PLACE
YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION A BABY TWO SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN THERE ARE
NOW. AND AT THIS TIME IF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING
UP. ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION TO COME
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IF I
MISTER SCHECK. NO FILED NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWENTY SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON AB ONE HUNDRED.
DRINKING WATER AND POINT.
DEVICES AND LEAD CONTENT IT'S A
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION SO MOVE
RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT. NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE HUNDRED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
HUNDRED. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF AB ONE HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. THE
LINE NUMBER THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BY NUMBER THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT SURE MEMBERS JERRY
DESMOND WITH PLUMBING
MANUFACTURERS INTERNATIONAL WE
HAVE A NEUTRAL POSITION ON THE
MEASURE AS NEGOTIATED WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SENATE YOU Q.
COMMITTEE AND WE APPRECIATE. OF
THE STRUCTURE OF THE MEASURE IN
ITS CURRENT FORM. BY NUMBER
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER
THIRTY NINE THE LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR QUESTION WOULD CALPERS THE
POINT OF AB ONE HUNDRED. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB ONE HUNDRED. THANK
YOU MEDICARE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE
HUNDRED. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
GIRL. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH A LINE NUMBER. AND PUT
YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE HUNDRED.
COULD PRESS ONE BUTTON THERE-
NOW. AND AT THE TIME OF THE DAY
WE HAVE NO ONE TO ONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION LET'S GO
TO APARTMENT FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL AND THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD I DO
NOT ANTICIPATE A FISCAL IMPACT
ASSOCIATED WITH THE STATURE.
ALL RIGHT HEARD FROM FINANCING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB ONE HUNDRED CLOSE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON AB ONE OH
FIVE. BY SOME REMEMBER HOLDEN
WHO IS NOT WAVING PRESENTATION
ON THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MR
HOLDEN ARE YOU HERE TO. 52% ON
THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
RESEARCHER I WAS- PREPARE TO
MAKE A PRESENTATION- I THINK
THAT THE POINTS OF THE BILL
HAVE BEEN- PRESENTED TO AND ARE
REPRESENTED IN THE ANALYSIS- I
WOULD JUST STATE THAT THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL TO ADDRESS
THE TIMES AS IT RELATES TO.
UPWARD MOBILITY FOR NOT ONLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR BOTH WOMEN AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE
BILL BE- GO TO SUSPENSE AND
THEN HOPEFULLY ROOT CANAL
SUSPENSE AND MAKE ITS WAY TO
THE FOR THE SENATE OUR IRISH
EIGHT. YOU'RE A PARTICULAR
REVIEW BY. I THANK YOU FOR THE
BRIEF COMMENTS- THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES LINED UP BUT WE'RE
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING HERE
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY
HERE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THIRTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH
FIVE ON UPWARD MOBILITY BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH FIVE.
PRESS ONE ZERO AND THE OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK IN
THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO NOW. ONE MOMENT SIR WOULD
YOU HAVE SOMEONE JOIN UP
TOGETHER IN THEIR LINE NUMBER
NOW. FORMER MINISTER THE
GOVERNOR LINE NUMBER. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE LINE NUMBER
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS TO THINK WORLD ON
WITH THE COALITION FOR JUSTICE
AT LOCALES GLORIA IS STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH FIVE THANK
YOU. SENATOR THOMAS THE CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE WERE OPPOSITION OF AB
ONE OH FIVE WILL OPEN IT UP
HERE IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY HERE THERE'S SO MANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. WATER IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB ONE OH FIVE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE OH
FIVE. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND PLACE YOU
BACK IN THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE OH FIVE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. AND
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO MONEY
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL COME TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FILE
THIS YEAR NO FILED NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB ONE OH
FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. GOING
ON TO. OUR NEXT BILL WHICH IS.
AB TWO TWO NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AND
PRIVATE INVESTIGATORS
PROPRIETARY SECURITY SERVICES
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE WILL MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODYTHERE MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWO NINE. THANK YOUNG.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWENTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE ONLINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE. THERE
ARE NOW. MY NUMBER THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING JERRY MEMBERS
JERRY DESMOND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION LICENSE
THE VESTED GATORS WE HAVE A
MUTUAL PROVISION POSITION ON
THE BILL AS RECENTLY AMENDED TO
ADDRESS THE PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR ACTOR MAKING CAR
BUYING CHANGES THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR THE ACCOMMODATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE DO
HAVE SOMEONE UP TO ANOTHER AT
THE MOMENT ONE MOMENT SIR. BY
NUMBER FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND MANY.
MORE I AM A CURRENT CITIZEN IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE THANK YOU AND
AS THE COURT. TO ORGANIZATIONS
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDER ON THERE ARE YOU
CHECKING AND IF YOU THINGS HERE
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME OF
THE DAY WE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT MOVE ON OPPOSITE OF
AB TWO NINE OR NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM IS OPEN TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO TWO TWO
NINE. THANK YOU. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OF AB TEN TWENTY
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE LINE NUMBER. AND PUT YOU
BACK IN THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO TWO NINE.
THREE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. AND
AT THIS TIME OF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME RETIREMENT FINANCE.
NO FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWO TWO NINE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON A. B.
TWO FOUR TWO BY HOLDING ON
PUBLIC UTILITIES. IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION SO MOVED TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM. IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IN SUPPORT MODERATES
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FOUR TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. IT WILL PROVIDE YOU THE
PMR NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK IN
THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. THE MOMENT MISTER
WOULD YOU HAVE TWENTY ONE UP.
MY NUMBER FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ECONOMIC WITHSTANDING A
CATHOLIC CHURCH IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO FOUR TWO HOLDEN THANK
YOU. AT THE TIME OF THE YEAR WE
HAVE NO LISTEN. ALL RIGHT ROAD
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO FOUR TWO
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS
OPEN TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IS
SUPPOSED AB TWO FOUR TWO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OF EIGHTY TWO
FORTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THREE ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND PLACE BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE DAY
THEIR- NOW. THE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIRMAN PHILLIPS TO ANOTHER
THE MOMENT. BY NUMBER TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
PARAMOUNT NOT THAT THE I LIVE
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY. I AM
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED EIGHTY
TWO FOUR TWO A MONTH IF THEY
REMOVED THEM COLLUSION OF
WILDFIRES DETERMINED TO BE
CAUSED BY AN ELECTRICAL
CORPORATION THANK YOU.
COMMENTED HERE WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE
TAKE IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WILL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FILE NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWO FOR TWO WITH A SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON AB THREE FOUR NINE BY
HOLDING ON SMALL BUSINESS
CONTRACTING OUT OF REACH. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE- AND
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC HEARINGS
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NO MINIMUM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
FOUR NINE. THANK YOU MEDICARE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE FORTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH A LINE NUMBER
AND PUSH BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FORTY NINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE
NOW. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE FOUR
NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY MODERATS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB THREE
FOUR NINE. THANK YOU. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE
FORTY NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK THE QUEUE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY THREE
FORTY NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE NOW. SENATOR
THOMAS HERE WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SHARE NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE FOUR NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
A. B. SIX FOUR ONE. HOLDEN
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIC
ELECTRONIC ELECTRIFICATION- IT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION MOVE
RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT ON
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE WELL WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
FOUR ONE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIX FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE ONLINE
NUMBER IT TAKES YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. SIX
FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO NOW. BUT AT THIS TIME OF
THIS YEAR WE HAVE NO ONE TO
YOU. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION WILL OPEN IT UP HERE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THIS COMPANY IN TWENTY FORTY.
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SIX FOUR
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AB
SIX FORTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF EIGHTY
SIX FORTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
IN THEIR OWN NOW. AT THIS TIME
A TEACHER WE HAVE NO ONE Q.
RIGHT REFERRED FROM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL HEAR FROM
FINANCE. FILE THIS JAN NO FILE
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB SIX FOUR ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON A. B. NINE
FORTY EIGHT BY HOLDEN ON REAL
ESTATE LICENSING. YOUR REAL
ESTATE APPRAISERS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE%
WAY PRESENTATION. AND WILL OPEN
A PUBLIC COMMENT HERE FORTY TWO
OR THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
WILL BE AROUND TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY THERE. ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
AT THE PORT OF EIGHTY NINE
FORTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. IT WILL HAVE WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER WILL TAKE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE
FORTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR OWN NOW. AND AT THIS
TIME IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE FORTY
EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. AB NINE FORTY EIGHT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB
NINE FORTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF. EIGHTY
NINE FOUR EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE BEEN THERE- NOW. AND AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
GO TO. THE THAT WAS SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. OPPOSITION TO A
COMEBACK ALTERNATIVES TO CHAIR
WILL COME BACK TO- FINANCE FILE
NO FILE MY QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. NINE FOUR EIGHT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
AB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN BY
HOLDING ON CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE AMAZON WHICH
DEVELOPMENT BANK WILL GO RIGHT
IT'S AUTHORS WAVE PRESENTATION
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL
RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT THAT
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THIS COMPANY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MEDICARE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB. ONE TWO NINE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN
THERE- NOW. AND AT THIS TIME IF
THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOTHING IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN. THANK YOU SIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE TWO
NINE SEVEN THIS PRESS ONE ZERO
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE ON LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OF AB. TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEIR THEIR OWN NOW. AT THE
TIME OF THE DAY WE HAVE KNOWING.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE OPPOSITE OF AB.
NINETY SEVEN. WILL OPEN UP IN
THIS ROOM DO WE DO OF. THAT WAS
OPPOSITION ARE MY FAULT SORRY.
BECAUSE IT FARMING FINANCE
THAT'S TWICE I DID THAT. LAST
YEAR NO FILE NO QUESTIONS. AND
WE WILL. PUT AB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN ON SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. LIVING ON A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN ON STATE AGENCY
RECORDS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE'LL MOVE
RIGHT INTO PUBLIC TESTIMONY
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. BATTERIES FOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU
SIR WOULD WANT IT YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN THE OF AB. TWENTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE ONLINE NUMBER AND PLACE
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE NOW.
AT THE TIME OF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO MONNING Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY-
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADY DYNAMITE IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION A BABY
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW.
AND AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO MONEY Q. RIGHT
HAVING HEARD FROM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITHIN FARMING OF
FINANCE ON A. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY NINE. MISTER CHAIR NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE
ON AB SEVENTY EIGHT FIVE
DONALD. SAN GABRIEL AND LOWER
LOS ANGELES RIVER AND MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY TERRITORY. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT HEARING ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE DAYS NOBODY
HERE ROOM OF YOUR ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NOBODY THERE. BUT
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE ONLINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN
THERE- NOW. LINE NUMBER FORTY
ONE THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SHOULD LOS ANGELES YOU CAN
SUPPORT IT WILL BE MORE. AB
FORTY SEVENTY EIGHT O'DONNELL.
AND AT THE TIME OF DAY CARE WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. I WROTE
OPPOSITION WILL OPEN UP IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY HERE WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTY
EIGHT. PRESS ONE. ZERO AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOU MY NUMBER. AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB SEVENTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS
ONE BEEN THERE ARE NOW. AND AT
THIS TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE
NO MONEY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION IS
THEIR FILE. TO FILE- FILE NO
QUESTIONS ABOUT OBJECTION AB
SEVENTY EIGHT. WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB FOUR EIGHTY SIX THE
EDUCATION ARMY MUST FILL AS OUR
NEXT BILL. THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION AT TO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S SOMEBODY HERE WILL MOVE
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE. TO ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF AB
FOUR EIGHT SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR EIGHTY
SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE ON LINE NUMBER AND
PUT YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR EIGHT SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE BEEN THERE- NOW. AND
AT THIS TIME OF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY
SIX- THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB
FORTY SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND OTTOMAN. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FOUR EIGHTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR
EIGHT. SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THERE ARE NOW. AND AT THE TIME
OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FORTY SIX
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. AND FILE A
FINAL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FORTY SIX WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR. O'DONNELL
STATE AIR RESOURCES BOARD ZERO
MESSAGE. ZERO AT EMISSIONS.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION.
AND WITHOUT- FURTHER ADO OF OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM. THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE ONLINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE. THERE ARE NOW. THE
LINE NUMBER FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS OF THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES PROPER SPONSOR AB ONE
FIVE TWO FOUR OR DONALD. AT THE
TIME OF THIS YEAR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT OVER
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
FOUR THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THIS COMPANY IN TWENTY
FORTY. MINORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OF AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE
BEEN THERE ARE NOW. AND AT THIS
TIME OF THE JOURNALISM Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL COME DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. FORMER FINANCE GEN NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE ACR
EIGHTY EIGHT O'DONNELL LONG
BEACH INTERNATIONAL GATEWAY
BRIDGE IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION OF
A RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM AND
SUPPORTERS SOMEBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SPORT MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR EIGHTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AC ARE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A C. R.
EIGHTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
TO THEIR OWN NOW. AND AT THE
TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE TO YOU ALL RIGHT WERE IN
OPPOSITION ACR EIGHTY EIGHT.
SIR ANYONE HERE NOW IS THERE
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY NOW IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES
OPPOSED ACR EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. ACR EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO. AND
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER. AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AC ARE EIGHTY
EIGHT. PERCENT WANTED THEIR OWN
NOW. COMMENTED HERE WE HAVE AN
OPENING TO YOU. ALL RIGHT. IT'S
FOUR IN OPPOSITION WILL COME
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE. NO FILE
MISTER CHAIR NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
ACR EIGHTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WERE MOVING ON THE A.
B. NINETY SEVEN IS ARIANNA
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE. INSULIN
AFFORDABILITY THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. AND THE
AUTHOR IS PRESENTING PLEASE
OFFER SOME BRIEF COMMENTS AND I
KNOW YOU HAVE WITNESSES. AND
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL BE BRIEF AS
WELL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN
AND RESPECT FOR YOUR TIME I
WILL GO AHEAD AND WAIVE
PRESENTATION FOR NINETY SEVEN
JUST WANNA LET YOU KNOW THAT I.
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS EVER
SINCE FINDING OUT THAT THIS WAS
A SUSPENSE CANDID SO. I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY HAVING-
CONCLUSIONS BY- THIS WEEK ON
THIS BILL. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU- THAT INCLUDE YOUR
WITNESSES AS WELL AND WE WERE
IF WE- ARE THE- TO LET SIT
GOODNESS BECAUSE YOU'RE THE
WITNESSES. HERE ON THE ON THE
PHONE LINE. THE CHAIR ALL RIGHT
SO- MICHIGAN'S. GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SHARE GONZALEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
DIABETES ASSOCIATION CO SPONSOR
AT EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN OCTANE
MY TIME ADDRESSING THE MOST
COMMON QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
TECHNICAL IMPACT OF EIGHTEEN
NINETY SEVEN WHICH WOULD EXEMPT
AND ONE FROM HEALTH PLAN
INSURANCE DEDUCTIBLES. BUT
COMMON QUESTION WE GET IS WILL
EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN INCREASE
INSURANCE PREMIUMS. AND THE
SHORT ANSWER IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE BURKE ANALYSIS FOUND
THAT EIGHTY NINETY FIVE WOULD
NOT INCREASE PREMIUM BY EVEN 1%
BACK BURKE FOUND TOTAL NOW
EXPENDITURES WOULD INCREASE BY
ONLY TWO POINT ZERO ZERO. 8%
FOR HONORABLY. IN FACT THE BILL
HAVE A PA FISCAL IMPACT ON THE
STATE GIVEN THE CORAL CORAL
BETWEEN CONVEYED NINETEEN
HOSPITALIZATION AND DIABETES
WHAT DOES THAT COMMON QUESTION
WE GET WHICH IS WHY IS BUT
THEY'LL ONLY APPLY IN ONE. AND
A SHORT ANSWER AT THE PEOPLE
TAKING POINT CONTROL THEIR- OR
75% MORE LIKELY TO. FROM KOBE
THEN ON AND POINT. A NEW STUDY
FOUND THAT 40% OF THEM. COULD
DIE A CO NIGHT. HAD DIED.
TROUBLES OUT OF EVERY IN MAY.
DIED FROM CALVIN NINETEEN WAS
BACK FROM. DIED ONE OF THE
HIGHER RISK DURING THE- ONE AND
TEN PEOPLE WITH DIABETES OR
HOSPITALIZED THE COSBY NINETEEN
DIED WITHIN. A WEEK. NOW THAN
EVER WE NEED TO ROOM BARRIERS
AND BUT COST BEING THE GREATEST
AREA AND ACTIVISTS THANK BODIES.
THAT TO FIRST PLAN PEOPLE HAVE
DIED THE HI GOOD THAT HEALTH
REGULAR GET THEIR MEDICARE. AND
BE OUT OF CAUGHT OUT OF POCKET
COSTS. AND ONE DON'T JUDGE
IMPACT PEOPLE HIGH DID HEALTH
PLANS THAT SAME STUDY FOR THAT
NINETEEN. OF THOSE ENROLLED IN
TRADITIONAL PLAN COULD NOT PAY
FOR THEIR EMPLOYMENT THE
OPENING OF THE AND IT ALREADY
HER OUT OF POCKET PROTECTION WE
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE LESS THAN A
MINUTE LEFT. FOR MS RAMIREZ. HI
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN TO BECOME
LAMINATOR MEREKA SERVICE THE
DIRECTOR PUBLIC AND
COMMUNICATIONS FOR THE HELP
TRUST THE COOK SIR NINE SEVEN.
AND HEALTHCARE NINE NINE
OPERATING. OKAY FOR OVER TEN WE-
COMMUNITY HEALTH THAT YOU FOR
PEOPLE WITH A- ACCORDING THEM
THE BETTER MAN SECOND- LET
HEALTH LIFE INTO THIS WORK WITH
PART AUBURN OVER. ABOUT THE
TOUGH CHOICES CALIFORNIANS HAVE
TO MAKE IN ORDER TO HAVE ACTIVE
IMPLANT. INTEGRALLY INTERRUPT
EIGHT MANY RESIDENTS ARE PAYING
UP TO HALF OF THEIR INCOME
TOWARD HOUSING FORCING PEOPLE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN PAYING RENT
COULD YOU PUT ON THE TABLE OR
BUYING THEIR LIFE. AND PLAN.
ASSETS WERE HOPEFUL THAT THIS
BILL WILL MOVE FORWARD IN ORDER
TO HELP THOSE WHO CREATE HIGH
OUT OF POCKET DEDUCTIBLE. FOR
IMPLANT AND CANNOT APPEAR TO
THEIR CARE PLAN INSTEAD THEY
RUSSIAN AND PLANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE NEED. THANK YOU. R. I. WE'VE
EXCEEDED OUR TIME OF WILL GO ON
TO THIS THERE'S NO HERE HOW
MANY ROOMS FIVE MODERATE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE WHICH TO SEE A B.
NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINETY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE BACK IN THE
QUEUE. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETY
SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. AT THE TIME OF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE I THINK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION OF AB NINETY SEVEN
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS
NOBODY TWENTY FORTY WINERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO AB NINETY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. I WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER AND PUSH
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB NINETY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THERE ARE NOW. AND AT
THE TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
HEARD FROM SUPPORT OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE ANTICIPATE MINOR
OBSERVABLE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL IS NOT
ESTIMATED TO HAVE AN IMPACT ON
CALPERS PLANS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION THE FATHER'S WAY FOR
THE PRESENTATION. AND THERE'S
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB NINETY SEVEN. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON AB TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER
HIS ARIAN PHYSICIANS IN SERVICE
SURGEONS PAYMENT DISCLOSURE
NOTICE THIS IS ALSO A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND THAT THE AUTHOR
IS HERE 2% SO MISTER NAZARIAN
TELL US BRIEFLY ABOUT AB TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT I'M-
HAPPY TO ALSO WAIVE MY
PRESENTATION ON THIS KNOWING
THAT THERE ARE TWO INDIVIDUALS
WHO CAN SPEAK ON THIS MATTER
FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE SO I.
AB THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
IT WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY
DEFERRED TO THE PRESENTERS ALL
RIGHT WE'LL MOVE RIGHT TO THE-
PHONE LINE WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES. DOCTOR ROSEN AND-
WHEN THE CSU. CONNECT. YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES TOTAL. BETWEEN
THE TWO OF YOU. ARE THEY THERE
MODERATOR YEAH. THE LINES ARE
OPEN. WE'RE HERE GO AHEAD OKAY
HI THANK YOU MY NAME TWENTY
CONNECT. SIX SURGERIES AND THE
SUFFERING I'VE ENJOYED BECAUSE
OF THE SURGEON WHO DID NOT
DISCLOSE A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
IN THE EXPERIMENTAL DEVICE
IMPLANTED INSIDE ME WITHOUT MY
KNOWLEDGE OR CONSENT SHOULD
NEVER HAPPEN TO ANYONE BUT IF
IT COULD HAPPEN TO ME IT COULD
HAPPEN TO YOU OR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. MY CASE AND
OUTRAGE TO THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY IN PASADENA MY
HUSBAND HAS BEEN A RESPECTED
GASTROENTEROL ENGINE FOR ALMOST
FORTY YEARS. THE DOCTORS AT
HUNTINGTON HOSPITAL WHO SENT
THE COURT LETTER TO THIS
COMMITTEE AT LEAST THIRTY ONE
THAT I KNOW OF DO NOT SHARE THE
VIEWS OF THE CMA PATIENTS HAVE
A RIGHT TO KNOW ONE DOCTOR
WROTE AND THE POSITION IN A
LARGE MEDICAL GROUP WE HAVE
ALWAYS CLOSED TIGHT ANY MEDICAL
OR DEVICE COMPANY. BECAUSE IT
IS NEEDED TO MAINTAIN AN OPEN
INTRACTABLE RELATIONSHIP WITH
OUR PATIENTS ROSE ANOTHER THAT
ETHICAL IN ITS COMMONSENSE
THESE FINANCIAL TIES ARE NOT
ALWAYS BAD BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THEY CAN AND DO LEAD TO
CONFLICT OF INTEREST THAT
AFFECT JUDGMENT WHICH MAY OR
MAY NOT BE IN THE PATIENT'S
BEST INTEREST. LETTING PATIENTS
KNOW ABOUT OPEN PAYMENT. THAT
IT MERELY EXIST IS A START IN
RIGHTING A WRONG KNOWLEDGE.
THAT WOULD HAVE CHANGED MY LIFE.
HEY NEED ALL THE INFO. TO MAKE
AN AT THE- HIDING THE TIES WILL
CAN. TO HARM. FROM THE BOTTOM
OF HEART I ASK YOU TO. NOT
PEOPLE LIKE ME AND ALL PATIENTS
IN THE DARK. PLEASE SHOW THAT
YOU CARE BY GIVING THEM THE
RIGHT TO KNOW. VITAL
INFORMATION THANK YOU. DR ROSEN.
YEAH I AM MY NAME IS CHARLES
ROSEN- PROFESSOR SURGERY AT
UCLA SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
PRACTICING PHYSICIAN FOR THIRTY
YEARS AS WELL AS PRESIDENT OF
THE ASSOCIATION MEDICAL ETHICS
I WORKED WITH SENATOR GRASSLEY
CALLED SPONSORING A POSITION
PAYMENT SUNSHINE ACT WHICH I
TESTIFIED BEFORE CONGRESS.
DURING PRESIDENT OBAMA'S FIRST
TERM. IN THE FIGURES RESIST
THIS HOMELESSNESS ARE HAVE ALL
RESEARCH MEDICAL PRACTICE YOUR
INDEPENDENT WITHOUT DENTAL
FINANCIAL BY. THIS TYPE OF
RESISTANCE IS NOW FROM THE CMA
NO ESTIMATES INDUSTRY LOBBYISTS.
IT SHOULD BE CRYSTAL CLEAR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WHERE
THEIR PRIORITIES LIE IT IS NOT
WITH PATIENT SAFETY AND CARE.
HOWEVER AN INVOLVED PATIENTS
BODIES AND THEIR LIVES AND HOW
THEY DARN WELL HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW ATTENTIONAL. BIAS BIG
DEBTS. TO BE CRYSTAL CLEAR
EIGHT TWELVE EIGHT ONLY A
ADDITIONS RESEARCH A PIECE OF
PAPER THE GIVES A THE ADDRESS
LIST. I WAS ON THE WALL WITH
ALL THE OTHER NO. ON THE DOCK
WORDS. THAT IS ALL NOTHING MORE
IF YOUR CALL. TO THE DECISION.
ON TRUE AMONG OTHERS THAT IT IN.
FILE CAN OF. AND LOTS OF EXPAND.
I'M A PRACTICING PHYSICIAN IN
THIS IS BURDENSOME THERE'S APPS
NETWORK. FOR THE LESS YOU BURN.
MARIN WRITING DISCLOSED ACCOUNT
OR- NAME NOTHING INTERFERE WITH
THE BILL. BUILDING FOR THIS
BILL A VOTE FOR TRANSFER. IN
PATIENT CARE MAKE NO MISTAKE TO
VOTE AGAINST IT IS THE VOTE FOR
SECRECY AND FOR INDUSTRY PROFIT
OVER PATIENT CARE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY WE'VE HEARD FROM
OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES. WE WILL
GO TO. GENERAL TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF. THIS BILL. AB
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
CHAIR LADIES INTO IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUSH YOU BACK INTO
Q. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE. TWO SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE PEOPLE
QUEUING UP. ONE MOMENT IS
GATHERING THE LINE NUMBER
MISTER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AT LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AARO
BROWN WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. AND AT THE TIME
OF THE DAY WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT REGARD
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. A.
B. TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OF AB TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT. PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OF AB TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THE NEW THEIR OWN NOW. BUT WE
DO HAVE PEOPLE QUEUING UP
NUMBERS TO SHARE WHY NUMBER
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TERRY
MEMBERS TEN NON REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY
ALLIANCE THE CALIFORNIA SIDED
PLASTIC SURGEONS THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF CARDIOLOGY IN OPPOSITION.
WHY NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT. BY NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE KEEP IT UP. BY NUMBER
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE NUMBER FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DIDN'T THE NUMBER OF THE
MORNING CARE AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS EMILY HUGHES CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
CHEWED UP FOR OPPOSITION OF AB
PLUS SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO THAT'S ONE THAN
THEIR OWN BEGIN OPPOSITION. AND
AT THE TIME OF THE JOURNALISTS
SHOWING UP. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION THE
AUTHORS WAVE FURTHER
PRESENTATION WE'RE GOING TO
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. YOU MISTER
CHAIR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS ESTIMATES THAT
ANY FISCAL IMPACTS RESULTING
FROM THIS BILL WOULD BE MINOR
IN A CIRCLE- FINANCE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
TWELVE. TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB
TWO FIFTEEN FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHU ON PLANNING AND
ZONING THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANTIK AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION- WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT HEARING ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. WE'LL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO FIFTEEN. THANK YOU MEDICARE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWO FIFTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN THERE ARE
NOW. MY NUMBER FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR HERE THIS IS BOB MALE
REPRESENTING FEELS COMPANY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. MY NUMBER
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANAFORT
BRITTANY GENERAL ATTORNEY
GENERAL BONTA IN SUPPORT OF. AT
THE TIME OF THE YEAR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. I MOVED
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO FIFTEEN
IS- NO ONE IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NO ONE IN TWENTY FORTY MODERATE
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO TWO FIFTEEN. THANK
YOU MEDICARE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OF AB TWO
FIFTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND
PUT YOU BACK TO Q. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. A BABY TO FIFTEEN.
PUSH PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. BY
NUMBER FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. RICHARD
MEMBERS. THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS CENTER POST AB TWO ONE
PUNCTURED. POLITE NUMBER FIFTY
FOUR THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DO BROKEN CENTER PARK
SIDE NEIGHBORHOOD SAN FRANCISCO
IN OPPOSITION. WHY NUMBER SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CAROL ROSS ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY THAT STOCKTON AND THE
MARIN COUNCIL BEAR WITH COUNCIL
MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION. THE LINE
NUMBER TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SHARING INVOLVED AS ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF CARLSBAD CORONA
EASTVALE BELMONT AFTER.
BAKERSFIELD IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU- MY NUMBER TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING MR TRAIN MEMBERS
I APOLOGIZE FOR THIS IMAGE TO
SUPPORT LINE BUT- THIS IS
WILLIAM BROUGH BURKE ABOUT HALF
OF THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
AND SUPPORT CALIFORNIA YIMBY
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING
IN URBAN RESEARCH IS THAT. THE
ASIAN ADVANCE HELP OPRY COMPANY
AND HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APOLOGIZE TO THE. MY NUMBER.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BIOTERROR AND WE HAVE THE SAN
LUIS OBISPO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION.
NUMBER THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JUSTIN HIRE
WORKERS WILL COME OUT
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND I
APOLOGIZE THE LINES ARE MIXED
UP BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO FIFTEEN THANK YOU. AT THE
TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU. I REFERRED
FROM SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL
COME BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT- ESTIMATES COST OF
NINETY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ON GOING TO.
COMPLETE INVESTIGATIONS. WOULD
KNOW THAT ANY REQUEST FOR
RESOURCES WILL. REPORTER THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS LASTLY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES ONGOING COST OF UP TO
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE LEGAL SERVICES
REVOLVING FUND THANK YOU. REFER
FROM FINANCE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS ABOUT OBJECTION AB
TWO FIFTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPEND
SAVE MOVING ON AB TWO FIVE TWO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS ON
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CAN ACCOMPLISH
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN ROOM.
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
THERE THERE'S NO MANY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO FIVE TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWO FIVE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE BACK
INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FIFTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR OWN NOW. AND AT THIS
TIME IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE I THINK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO FIVE TWO
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THIS COMPANY TWENTY FORTY IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO TWO FIVE TWO. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF EIGHTY
TWO FIFTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB TWO FIVE
TWO. THREE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE- NOW. AND AT THIS TIME IF
THIS YEAR WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT. BERMAN FINANCE. IF I
HAD. A FINAL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION TO FIVE TWO GOES TO
SUSPENSE AB THREE SIXTEEN
COOPER STATE EMPLOYEES PAY
EQUITY. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANNON OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT HERE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. FIGHTERS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PUSH BACK IN THE QUEUE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIXTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN THERE-
NOW. AT THE TIME OF THE CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. MOVED-OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THE SEVEN TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR WHEN ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO
THREE SIXTEEN. WAITED A MOMENT
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE SIXTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PUT YOU
BACK INTO s
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB THREE SIXTEEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO DOWN. AND AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE. NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE SIXTEEN WILL
GO THROUGH SUSPENSE MOVING N
AB THREE FIVE NINE BY COOPER
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS
LICENSURE EXAMINATION IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE WILL
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY THERE.
MODERATOR'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF THREE FIVE
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE FIFTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO NOW.
ONE MOMENT THE CHAIR NUMBER
FIFTY THREE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ZURCHER BOB
NEAL REPRESENTING VIJAY ARORA
M. D. NG IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER WOULD
YOU HAVE SOMEONE OF CLEAN UP
ONE MOMENT THERE. MY NUMBER
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD- GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS ADRIN MOHAMMED WITHOUT
MEDICAL. IN SUPPORT. THE LETTER
COMMENTED HERE WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE COULD YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB THREE
FIVE NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY TWENTY
FORTY IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED. THREE FIVE NINE.
LATER ON IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE FIFTY
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. IT WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE ONLINE NUMBER AND PUT YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AB
THREE FIFTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE BEEN THERE ARE NOW. HI
NUMBER THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AARON BROWN WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THE
BORDERS IN A CLOSE THE MOST
AMENDED POSITIONS THAN WE
EXPECTED PROPOSED DOCUMENTS
WILL RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS WITH
THE MEDICAL EXAMINATION PORTION
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. AND AT THE TIME OF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NOW WHEN I THINK
YOU ALL RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE.
FILE THIS YEAR- FILES NO
QUESTIONS ABOUT OBJECTION AB
THREE FIVE NINE WITH A SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON MAYBE TEN SEVENTY
COOPER ALCOHOL BEVERAGE GIVE
RESTRICTIONS. THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE OFFERS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOT ANY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATE SURE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE. THAT IS.
SUPPORT OF AB TEN SEVENTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
SEVENTY. FIVE ONE ZERO AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER IN PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TEN SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEIR OWN NOW. AND AT THE
TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
MONNING Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB TEN SEVENTY. THANK
YOU MEDICARE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OF AB TEN
SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND
PLACE BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE ZERO SEVEN
ZERO. PLEASE PRESS ONE THERE
ARE NOW. THE LETTER THOMAS IS
HERE WE HAVE NO MONEY TO YOU.
ALL RIGHTS PART IN FINANCE.
FILE FINAL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TEN SEVENTY.
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB.
THREE SEVENTEEN BY PATTERSON ON
FOSTER CARE. IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES HE OFFERS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE THERE'S NOT ANY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE. LINE IN
SUPPORT OF THREE SEVENTEEN.
THANK YOU MEDICARE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
AT. OF AB THREE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PUT YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SEVENTEEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO MONEY TO
SPARE. WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THIS NUMBER IN TWENTY FORTY IS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB THREE SEVENTEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE
SEVENTEEN. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER AND PUT
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THREE SEVENTEEN. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEIR THEIR OWN NOW.
AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
MANY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE. AND
FILE NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION THREE
SEVENTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVIE ON AB THREE SEVENTY NINE
GALLAGHER WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT. THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
IN TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVEN NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUSH BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPETH IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR OWN NOW. AND AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ACCUSER.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
OF AB THREE SEVENTY NINE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THIS COMPANY IN TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO THREE SEVENTY NINE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB THREE SEVENTY NINE. POINT
FIVE ONE ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER. AND PUSH BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE SEVEN
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN
THERE ARE NOW. AT THIS TIME IF
THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD THE
DEPARTMENT EFFICIENT WILDLIFE
AND THE NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION ESTIMATE
MINOR OBSERVABLE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SPELL. OF
WOULD NOTE THAT THE OMINOUS
RESOURCES TRAILER BILL AB ONE
FORTY EIGHT AT THE- BONTA AS AN
ELIGIBLE RECIPIENT FUND FOR
RESOURCES RELATED TO THE
SECTION OF WALL. AND THIS BILL
APPEARS INADVERTENTLY CHAPTER
OUT THAT LANGUAGE THAT WAS PART
OF THE RECENTLY ENACTED BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
HEARD FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SEEING NO QUESTIONS
ABOUT OBJECTION THREE SEVEN
I'LL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
AB FOR SEVENTY EIGHT BY SEVENTY
MEMBERS TAKING. ON SOLID WASTE
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. SEVENTY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY FOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF FOR SEVEN
EIGHT. THANK YOU MEDICARE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PUT YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO THEIR OWN NOW. NUMBER
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOR SEGMENTING.
LINE NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS WE HAVE
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT OF AB
COURSE IN THE EIGHT. AND AT THE
TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION FOR SEVENTY
EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOT MANY TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE TO ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT. THE MESSAGE CARE LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF AB FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEIR OWN NOW. MY NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS GAIL DELLA HANNAH WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO- AB
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THE LINE NUMBER FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JIM SHIFTING WITH
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
CURRENTLY AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. AND AT
THE TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE WOULD YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES
RECYCLING AND RECOVERY
ESTIMATES COST OF FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE AND SIX HUNDRED
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. AND ONGOING ADDITIONALLY
CAL RECYCLE THOSE THAT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WOULD BE
REQUIRED IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX THE AUDIT PLASTIC
THE REFORM PRODUCERS. BUT WOULD
NOT THIS BILL DOES REQUIRE
IMPORTERS AND MANUFACTURERS TO
PAY REGISTRATION FEES. TO COVER
THE REASONABLE REGULATORY COST
OF THE BILL. AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MAY NEED TO INVEST
AN ADDITIONAL RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SEPARATE THE
REFORM PLASTIC CONTAINERS AND
OTHER CONTAINERS. TO RECEIVE
THE COMMINGLED RECYCLING RATE
AND COSTS FOR ADDITIONAL
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD
LIKELY BE PASSED ON TO
RESIDENTS DURING INCREASING
GARBAGE COLLECTION RATES.
HARVARD FOR FINANCE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FOR SEVENTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. AB TWELVE R. ONE
TAKING SOLID WASTE PRODUCTS
LABELING THIS IS A SUSPENSE CAN
AID OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THIS COMPANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE OH
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE OH ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWELVE
ALL ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEIR OWN NOW. THE WOMAN
DECISION WE DO HAVE PEOPLE
QUEUING UP THIS GATHERING LINE
NUMBERS. LINE NUMBER FIFTEEN
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER MEMBERS COLLIER
MAY HAVE SITTING COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO HAVE A SPORT IT'S
AMENDED ON THIS ONE- MORE
QUICKLY UP THERE ON THE-
TECHNICAL. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS JUMPED
ON THE LINE HERE FOR THE-
CALIFORNIA COMPOSED COALITION A
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. AND ALSO
THE ELEVEN MEMBERS OF THE CLEAN
SEAS LOBBY COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF TWELVE OH ONE THANK
YOU. THE LINE NUMBER FORTY ONE
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TROUBLE WANTING.
AT THE TIME OF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN QUEUE ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION OF
AB TWELVE A ONE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE. OPPOSED TO
TWELVE A ONE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWELVE R. ONE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER. AND PUT YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE ALL ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE BEEN THERE- NOW. AND AT
THIS TIME OF THE SUMMER WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WOULD
TAKE ITS FOREIGN OPPOSITION
FINANCE. L. RECYCLE ESTIMATES
COSTS OF ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
INTEGRATED WASTE MANAGEMENT
ACCOUNT IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. AND ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ONGOING WOULD KNOW THEN
INTEGRATED WASTE MANAGEMENT
ACCOUNT IS CURRENTLY A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. WITH
EXPENDITURES EXCEEDING REVENUES
BY SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND ANY ADDITIONAL
COSTS OR COST PRESSURES WHAT
EXACERBATING STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT. AND FURTHER
NECESSITATE THE NEED TO
INCREASE THE TO BE WHICH IS AT
THE STATUTORY MAXIMUM THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT REFERRED FOR FINANCE
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWELVE ALL ONE
WILL GO MOVING ON
TO AB FIVE FIVE NINE BY
ARAMBULA- SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY IT'S A SUSPENSE
JANET AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION.
WILL OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NO GREEN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE FIVE NINE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF AB
FIVE FIVE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE NOW. AT THIS
TIME IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE WE HAVE NO ONE Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION A
FIVE FIVE NINE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
FIVE FIVE NINE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OF EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTY NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND PUSH BACK IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIVE FIVE NINE. PLEAE PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. MY NUMBER FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS VOLUME WE HAVE THE
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS IN FRESNO
AND MADERA COUNTY STILL IN
OPPOSITION. AT THE PHARMACY
CARE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN
QUEUE RIGHT DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY
ESTIMATES ANY COSTS RESULTING
FROM THIS BILL WOULD BE MINOR
AND SEVERAL. WE WOULD KNOW THAT
THE BILL MAY IMPOSE A
POTENTIALLY REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE HOWEVER WE ANTICIPATE
ANY MPACT TO BE. MINOR THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD ROM
FINANCE WITHOUT OBJECTION-
CHINO QUESTIONS ABOUT OBJECTION
AB FIVE FIVE NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. SB SIX FORTY TWO
FRIEDMAN ON WILDFIRES THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT. IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SIX
FOUR TWO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIX FORTY TO CONFESS ONE
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX FORTY TWO.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE
NOW. AT THE TIME OF THE DAY WE
HAVE AN OPENING Q. I WOULD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THEY'RE HAVING TWENTY
FORTY MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SIX FORTY
TWO. THE MESSAGE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SIX
FORTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEY'RE ALL. AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER IN CASE YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB SIX FORTY
TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
AT THE TIME OF DAY CARE WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN. A SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO PRIVATE
FINANCE. FILE NO FINAL
QUESTIONS THAT OBJECTION SIX
FORTY TO. GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON AB TEN TWENTY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN IT'S HEALTHCARE
DEBT AND FAIR BILLING. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE JANET AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. OF PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
FIGHTERS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF TEN TWENTY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LOSING
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN TWENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOU MY NUMBER AND PUSH BACK
INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
TWENTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
NOW. AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. RIGHT WING
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN TWENTY.
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR ANYONE OPPOSED TO TEN
TWENTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB
TEN TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TEN TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE NOW. ANOTHER
COMMENTED HERE WE HAVE NO ONE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCED YOU
HAVE A FILE. YES YOU CARE THANK
YOU THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE ACCESS AND INFORMATION
ESTIMATES COST OF THREE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE THREE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. AND THREE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING ON THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH DATA AND
PLANNING FUND. ON THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA- ESTATE MINOR
SEVERAL COST RELATED TO THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU WE'VE TAKEN
FOR FINANCE WE WILL NEVER OF
MEMBERS TO FUNCTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TEN TWENTY. WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON AB
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN BY FRIEDMAN
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLAN.
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP PUBLIC HEARING THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S SOMEBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE IF ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PUT YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE ONE FOUR SEVEN. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. LINE NUMBER
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
WILLIAMSON BURKE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BEING IN SUPPORT.
BY NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN A LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE CALL PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
DAVID AS A VETO IT SAYS YOU
TAKE TRACTOR AARP CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF PART THREE MILLION
MEMBERS WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT.
CONNECTED COMMENTED HERE WE
HAVE A LOT OF CONFUSION. OVER
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY. OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE- OPPOSED TO ONE FORTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE IT
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AB
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN BECAUSE
THAT'S ONE ZERO NOW. AT THE
TIME OF THE DAY WE HAVE NO ONE
TO YOU. ALL RIGHT WITH TECH
SUPPORT OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. I CALTRANS ESTIMATES
ONE TIME COST OF 750-001-0050
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM STATE
HIGHWAY ACCOUNT REPAIR THE
PILOT PROGRAM. AND TO THE PILOT
BE IMPLEMENTED YOU CALTRANS
WOULD INCUR ADDITIONAL FUTURE
COSTS OF AN UNKNOWN AMOUNT.
THAT THAT MAY BE IN THE RANGE
OF 300-550-0029 HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING FROM
THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT. DEAR
RESOURCES BOARD ESTIMATES COST
OF SIX HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE COST
IMPLEMENTATION ACCOUNT IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND SIX HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN. THREE AND I'M GOING
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
ESTIMATES COST OF THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND FOR ONE YEAR IN
ORDER TO REGISTER WORKLOAD IN
THE STILL AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
JUST ESTIMATES FOR TWO HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND COSTS FOR
CONSULTING CONTRACT TO DEVELOP
THE GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS
SPECIFIED IN THE MEASURE. BOTH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. REPORT AT THE
BILITY TO ABSORB THE WORKLOAD
INCREASES. S. MEASURE AND
LASTLY THIS BILL MAY CREATE
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE LOCAL
AGENCIES THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE HEARD FROM FINANCE SENIOR
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
ONE FORTY SEVEN GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON AB SEVEN TWENTY ONE
BLOOM ON COVENANTS AND
RESTRICTIONS. OR FOR A HOUSING
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
ON HIS WAY PRESENTATION SO MOVE
RIGHT INTO PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THAT HAVE A ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE.
COMMENTS
HERE I ORDERED OPPOSITION OF
SEVEN TWENTY ONE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM IS COMMON IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY FORTY
IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SEVEN TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OF EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE- NOW. AND AT THIS
TIME OF YEAR WE HAVE NO MONEY
Q. RIGHT WITHOUT A FARM IN
FINANCE. APARTMENT HOUSE AN
ESTIMATE MINERS ARE LOW COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS MEASURE WE
KNOW THAT THE BILL MAY IMPOSE A
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT- BUT
INDETERMINATE STATE REVERSIBLE
MANDATE BY REQUIRING COUNTY
COUNCILS MAY NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO LEVY CHARGES ON
NON COUNTY AND EASTER FORMER
APARTMENTS AFTER THE STILL.
I'VE HEARD FOR FINANCE. WE WILL
GO TO MEMBERS NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION MAYBE SEVEN
TWENTY ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVIE ON A. B. SEVEN TWENTY
THREE BY HELLO LINE FAR AND
DRIVER'S LICENSE IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. ON HIS WAY
PRESENTATION OPEN UP PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM IS COMING TWENTY FORTY.
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SEVEN
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. SEVEN TWENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO. AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B. SEVEN
TWENTY THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE NOW. AND AT THIS
TIME IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITIONISTS HEAVEN TWENTY
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM IS COMING IN TWENTY FORTY
IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SEVEN TWENTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES%
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF A. B.
SEVEN TWENTY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND PUT YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
A. B. SEVEN TWENTY THREE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THERE ARE
NOW. AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. I WILL GO TO PARMA
FINANCE. IN A MOTOR VEHICLE
SENT TO SPACE COST OF ONE
HUNDRED FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND ONE HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND FOUR
HUNDRED ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. WITH COSTS INCREASING
EACH YEAR THERE AFTER FOR THE
MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT. I WOULD
KNOW THAT THE- MBA IS CURRENTLY
RUNNING AN OPERATING DEFICIT.
AND ANY INCREASE IN
EXPENDITURES FROM THE ACCOUNT.
WHAT IS. EXACERBATING THE
CURRENT POTENTIAL INSOLVENCY OF
THE FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU SINGLE
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
THAT OBJECTION A. B. SEVEN
TWENTY THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON A. B. FIFTEEN
THIRTY SIX- BMP COMMITTEE BILL
IT IS- SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
PRESENTATIONS BEEN WAIVED. ON
BOARD OF VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC. YEAH WE'LL GO
RIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
FIFTEEN. THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A B. FIFTEEN
THIRTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A B.
FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THERE ARE NOW. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ARBOR OPPOSITION A FIFTEEN
THIRTY SIX THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NO MEAN
TWENTY FORTY BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT OF MINE
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ALL. I WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE O. LINE NUMBER AND PUT
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
A BABY FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE IN THEIR OWN
NOW. AND AT THIS TIME IF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
RIGHT WE'VE GOT APARTMENT
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT IN THE STATE'S LONG TERM
FISCAL PLAN PROVIDES FOR THE
BOARD'S CONTINUING BUDGET. IN
ADDITION THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS ESTIMATES TO
BOARD A LONGER COST OF FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. IN THE FIRST YEAR AND
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND SECOND YEAR. TO
ADDRESS INCREASED WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS MEASURE. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THESE
RESEARCHERS ARE LIKELY NEEDED
ON AN ONGOING BASIS BUT GIVEN
THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN THE
COURTS FIND. ABOARD A LIKELY
ONLY REQUEST RESOURCES ON A TWO
YEAR TERM BASIS. UNTIL THE
BOARD CAN DETERMINE THE ACTUAL
REVENUES ARE MATERIALIZING AS
ANTICIPATED. I WOULD NOTE THAT
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
ALSO ESTIMATES. OF THE BOARD
WILL INCUR SAVINGS UP TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
I DID A PROJECT IT SHOULD
CEASE. LASTLY THE PHARMACY
WHERE FIRES ESTIMATES NEW
REVENUES OF APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
WITH AN INCREMENTAL INCREASE.
OF FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH
YEAR THEREAFTER. THANK YOU
SINGING UP QUITE FOR MARK. WERE
OUT OF A BUFFET THIRTY SIX GO
THIS IS. MOVING ON IT A. B.
EIGHT OH FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DALI. WHO'S HERE TO PRESENT IT
TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
PLEASE COME UP AND PRESENT-
BRIEFLY APPRECIATE. GOOD
MORNING. EIGHTY EIGHT OH FOUR
AS A SIMPLE BILL THAT WILL
CHANGE A ME TO A SHELL IN
CURRENT LAW AND REQUIRE RATHER
THAN AUTHORIZE THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE TO DECLARE TO FREE
HUNTING DAYS THE COST OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD BE MINOR
AN OBSERVABLE I WOULD HELP THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCIALLY IF NEW
HUNTERS TAKE UP THE SPORT AND
PURCHASE ANNUAL HUNTING
LICENSES THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
VOTE NO ON THE PHONE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AS BILL
GAINS IN SUPPORT. AWESOME THANK
YOU WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY HERE I'M IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OTHER
THAN OUR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND SUPPORT OF AV EIGHT OH FOUR.
THANK YOU. RICHARD LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. EIGHT OH
FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER. AND
PUSH BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OF A. B. EIGHT OH FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THERE ARE NOW.
HELLO MY MESSAGES IS GATHERING
LINE NUMBERS. ONE MOMENT HERE
BY NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
BILL GAINS AND I AM PLEASED TO
BE SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCILMAN FOR
CONSERVATION THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THE WILD SHEEP
FOUNDATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEER ASSOCIATION AND NINE OTHER
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF EIGHTY EIGHT OH
FOUR. YOU CAN NEVER PUTTING
LIFE IN PRISON RELATED PERMITS.
AND THE ANNUAL REVENUES THEY
GENERATE FOR OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE FOR PROGRAMS
AND PROJECTS. IMPORTANT OR
STATE WILDLIFE- DRIVE OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AT THE
TIME OF THE DAY WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. I WILL GO TO A
POSITION OF AVIATOR FOR. OVER
THE PHONE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY EIGHT OH
FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO.
AND THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND
PUT YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY EIGHT OH
FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE- NOW. BUT AT THE TIME OF
THE DAY WE HAVE NO MONEY TO
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM
SUPPORT OPPOSITION IS OUR FILE.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
ESTIMATE ONE TIME COST OF ONE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE FISHING GAME
PRESERVATION FUND. TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS MEASURE.
BUT APARTMENT ADDITIONAL NOTES
OF THE BILL MAY INCREASE
LICENSE REVENUES- BUT ALSO
KNOWS THAT WE'RE JUST GETTING
INTO FREE HUNTING DAY I MAY NOT
PROVIDE ENOUGH INCENTIVE TO
DRIVE TO ATTRACT NEW HUNTERS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE HEARD
FROM FINANCE JUST FOR THE
RECORD THERE WAS NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE FOUR ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF BABY EIGHT OH
FOUR. IT IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WOULD YOU LIKE
TO MAKE A- BRIEF CLOSE. EXPECT
LAST FOREVER MY FAVORITE KIND
OF CLOSE WE NEED A MOTION.
HELLO WE HAVE THREE MOTIONS
MORE THAN A THIRD PAGE AND CALM
WATER- SO WE HAVE MOTIONS
GALORE SO MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT ZERO FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR FORTINO HI
DO YOU KNOW HI SENATOR BATES
BATES FIVE BRADFORD BRADFORD HI
JONES JONES BY CATALOGUER I AM
A- I'D LAYERED HI THERE FIVE
MORE CASKEY HI CASKEY ARE AT
SEVEN ZERO WE HAD A FULL HOUSE
THAT PHYLLIS OUT THANK YOU.
MOVE RIGHT ON TO A. B. NINE
EIGHT FOUR FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOSE REAVIS THIS IS A- SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATIONS. SAN I DON'T KNOW
I'M SORRY WE HAVE A B. NINE ONE
BY MR BENNETT. EIGHTY NINE FOR
ONE BY MR BANNON ON FAR MORE
PERSISTENCE THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHOR'S WAY
PRESENTATION. WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS HERE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FIVE OF FORTY TWO
OH THREE THIS COMING IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. FIGHTERS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. NINE FORTY ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B. NINE
FORTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE ONLINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. NINE FORTY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE- NOW. AND AT THIS TIME IF
THE CHAIR WE HAVE N MONEY TO.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THIS NUMBER IN TWENTY
FORTY MODERATES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO NINE
FORTY ONE. THANK YOU MR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
NINE FORTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND TAKE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD BE
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY NINE
FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. NOW. AT THE TIME OF THE
DAY WE HAVE AN OPENING Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. ON A. B. NINE FORTY
ONE- WILL GO TO FINANCE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR AT THIS BILL IS
SUBJECT TO AN APPROPRIATION AND
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT APPROPRIATE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR THIS GRANT PROGRAM. WE KNOW
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT IS IT IN A FIGHT
INDETERMINATE GENERAL FUND
COSTS RELATED TO. THE WORKLOAD
IS. WHICH WILL BE DRIVEN BY THE
NUMBER OF GRANT ADMINISTERED.
WHICH IS SUBJECT TO FUTURE
DEPARTMENTAL AND WORKING GROUP
DETERMINATION AS WELL AS
COUNTER PROTEST ASIAN. D.
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT DOES NOT
EXPLICITLY COVERED THESE COSTS
IN THE APPROPRIATION NOR DISCO
CLOSE BILL. ADDITIONALLY THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
APPROPRIATIONS FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO ONLY AN
ORGY EVALUATION REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT MISSISSIPPI
WORKLOAD COST BEYOND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. LASTLY
THE COST OF THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. DEBATE
ON THE WORKING GROUP ARE
ESTIMATED TO BE MINOR OBSTACLE.
I REFER FROM FINANCE WITHOUT
OBJECTION MAYBE NINE FORTY ONE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB NINETY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LUCRETIUS. IT IS A VEHICLE
IDENTIFICATION REGISTRATION
ALTERNATIVE DEVICES IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANADA IT OFFERS WAY
PRESENTATION. WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NO BE
TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE. LINE IN
SUPPORT OF NINETY FOUR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY FOUR THIS PRESS ONE
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE BACK IN TWO Q. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WOULD BE AT THE POINT OF.
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR PACIFIC
ONE. IN THEIR OWN NOW. LINE
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JIM
LIGHTS ON BEHALF OF REVIVER WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING- WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AS THE SPONSOR
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
THE CHP THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY ON AMENDMENTS TO GUIDE
THEIR IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PROGRAM ALONG WITH AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS AND
COMMENTS FROM A VARIETY OF
STAKEHOLDERS WE WELCOME YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE LINE NUMBER
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER
THIRTY ONE MAYBE I NEED. BY
THIRTY ONE THE LINE IS OPEN. AT
THE TIME OF THE DAY WE HAVE NO
ONE I THINK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION- THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS NOBODY
TWENTY FORTY MODERATES ANYONE
OPPOSED. TO NINETY FOUR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEY'RE ALL. IT WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF A. B.
NINE EIGHT FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THERE ARE NOW. MY
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
NUMBERS CATALINA SANCHEZ WITH
CORBIN AND CRIED THERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION AND PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE WE HAVE A
POSITION AS OPPOSED TO LIKE
THEM AND THANK YOU. AT THE TIME
OF THE YEAR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
CAN QUEUE. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO PARMA FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
ANTICIPATES COST OF FIVE
HUNDRED ELEVEN THOUSAND AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AND NINE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT. IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND ON
GOING- WE WOULD KNOW THAT THE
MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT IS
CURRENTLY RUNNING ON AN
OPERATING DEFICIT. AND AS OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT IT IS ESTIMATED THAT THE
RESERVES IN THE ACCOUNT MAYBE
NEARLY EXHAUSTED BY THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY. AND MAYBE
INSOLVENCY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. AND ANY INCREASE
IN EXPENDITURES FROM THE
ACCOUNT ABOUT THE EXISTING
BASELINE WILL EXACERBATE THE
FISCAL PRESSURES ON THE FUND.
LASTLY THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL ESTIMATES THESE PROPOSED
CHANGES WOULD HAVE A MINOR. AN
OBSERVABLE FISCAL IMPACT TO
THEIR DEPARTMENT. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE HEARD FROM FINANCE- I SEE
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
A. B. NINE EIGHTY FOUR WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO.
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL ON
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANADA OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION WITH ALL RIGHT
PUBLIC COMMENT. THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF NINE EIGHT NINE.
THANK YOU MESSAGE HERE LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK IN
THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. E. NINE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE- NOW. MY
NUMBER SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARK
STIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND STRONG
SUPPORT. AND AT THIS TIME IF
THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE I
THINK YOU. ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD
OPPOSITION OF A. B. NINE EIGHT
NINE. NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR FOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO NINE
EIGHT NINE. THANK YOU SHARE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOU MY NUMBER AND PLACE IT BACK
IN THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF HE
WAS A BIG OPPOSITION OF A. B.
NINE EIGHT NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. THE LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAROL ROSS
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BURBANK AT THE MARIN COUNTY
COUNCIL OF MAYORS AND COUNCIL
MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION. EIGHTY
NUMBER TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WILLIAM AT THE BURKE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
TO RESOLVE THE ISSUES
IDENTIFIED IN OUR LETTER THANK
YOU. THE LINE NUMBER FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EGYPTIAN MEMBERS OF CITY
OF BEVERLY HILLS AND HOSTED A
B. NINE EIGHT NINE. AT THE TIME
OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK TO FARMING TO FINANCE ON
NINE EIGHTY NINE. DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. ESTIMATES COST OF
THREE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ONGOING. DEVELOPMENT
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL COULD
ADD TO THE COURTS. WORKLOAD
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT REFERRED
FROM FINANCING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION NINETY NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
A. B. TWELVE SEVENTY SIX. A
RADIO SINGLE USE FOOD WHERE IT
IS A SUSPENSE CAN AT OFFICE
PLAY PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS NOW
BEING TWENTY FORTY. FOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A B. TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE BACK IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A B.
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE BEEN THERE- NOW. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS NOT ON
COOPER FROM NIELSEN MARKS WERE
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF
MARIN AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LIE NUMBER SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY NUMBER SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MAYBE YOU'RE ON MUTE.
MY NUMBER SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SURE CLEARLY TREE ON
BEHALF OF PACMAN IN SUPPORT OF
THE TRANSIT TIMES FOR THIS BILL.
BY NUMBER FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING HEARING MEMBERS OF
BEVERLY HILLS IN SUPPORT OF
MAYBE TWELVE TWENTY SIX READ.
MY NUMBER SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
STANDARD QUESTION ON BEHALF OF
HELP IN SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX. WELL I NUMBER
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. READINGS
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
DUSTIN MALONE ON BEHALF OF THE
ELEVEN MEMBERS OF THE TEAM SEES
ROBBIE COALITION THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL AND ALSO RECORDING
STRONG SUPPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOST COALITION
AND HEAL THE BAY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP IN SANTA
MONICA. THANKS VERY MUCH. LINE
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS SHEILA MOORE ABADI AND
THE FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF
HABITS OF WASTED .ORG AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
PRAYER MEMBERS MY NAME IS LI
HEALTHCARE AND ON BEHALF OF THE
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION WEARING
STRONG PUSH FOR A BEAUTIFUL
THANK. YOU. MY NUMBER SEVENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING DONNA
THANKS REPRESENTING A LOT THE
ANGELUS COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORTING
EIGHTY TWELVE SEVENTY THANK YOU.
BLIND NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD- YOU'RE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY SERVICES GOOD SPORT. THE
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JENNIFER APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF OCEANIA AND OCEAN
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY TWELVE SEVENTY SIX.
AND AT THIS TIME OF YEAR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN KILL I
COULD HAVE SOMEONE ELSE DO NOT
NOW ONE MOMENT. YEAH. THEY TAKE
YOURSELF OUT OKAY. AND AT THE
TIME OF THE DAY WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THIS COMING TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. A. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND PLACE BACK IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF A B.
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AT THIS
TIME A TEACHER WE HAVE NO MONEY
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL GO TO
FINANCE. A FILE. NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION. A.
B. TWELVE SEVENTY SIX COSTA
SUSPECTS A. B. FORTINO FIVE
WICKS. ON DEBT SETTLEMENT
PRACTICES IS A SUSPENSE CANNON
AUTHORS. WAY PRESENTATION. AND
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBDY IN. TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE- IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FORTINO FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. FOURTEEN OH FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND PUT YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FOURTEEN OH FIVE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEY'RE WRONG NOW.
SENATOR THOMAS INSURE WE HAVE
NORMALLY KILL RIGHT ROAD
OPPOSITION- NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
HAVING TWENTY FORTY. FOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO A.
B. FOURTEEN OH FIVE. I'M SORRY
TO HEAR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WHAT. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
A. B. FOURTEEN OH FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE LINE NUMBER AND PUT YOU
BACK IN THE QUEUE ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF A. B. FOURTEEN OH FIVE PUSH
PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE NOW.
BY NUMBER SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MATURE MEMBERS DOMINIC MAR IN
BEHALF OF THE TERM MUG GROUP
OPPOSING THE CEMENT THAT.
ANOTHER TIME A TEACHER WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
CARMEN FINANCE. ENVIRONMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION ESTIMATES COST OF
ONE HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE FINANCIAL
PROTECTION FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND I'M GOING TO.
ASSOCIATE WITH THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE STILL. ALL RIGHT WE FOR
FINANCING- QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION MAYBE FOURTEEN OH
FIVE GOES TO SUSPENSE OUR FINAL
BILL AS A B. FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX. MEDINA STUDENT FINANCIAL
AID THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S
NOBODY HERE IN TWENTY FORTY.
SEVENTY TWO MILLION FORTY TWO
OR THREE THERE'S NOBODY TWENTY
FORTY MODERATES ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW. BUT
ONE CAN THEREFORE SUPPORT. MY
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CHECK WITH THE PLANNER
MEMBERS KITCHEN ISLAND AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT A GOOD QUESTION. LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN ALEX WILL GO
FURTHER THAN IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY COMMISSIONED IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. I NUMBER
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JUSTIN HIGHER WITH THIS ALL
COME BY LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX THANK YOU.
POLITE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER GONZALEZ
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE TEN A
GOVERNOR OF ANY GONNA LOCK IT
AND SUPPORTED AP FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX THANK YOU. POLITE NUMBER
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ADAM DOT LEAVE ON BEHALF OF
UNITED LA HIM STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE P. FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX. THE
LINE NUMBER THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING GENTLEMEN HE
LEARNED ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
ADVOCATE AND MARK AND AT.
FOURTEEN FIFTY. THE LINE NUMBER
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DURING
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ENTRY ENTRY UP
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU PART OF A B. ONE FOUR
FIVE SIX MILLION. ONE MOMENT
THAT WE DO HAVE SOMEONE SHOWING
UP AT THE MOMENT. LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
MORNING MANY DEER PERFECT
PENALTY OCCURRING TO ME BECAUSE
THIS REQUIREMENT FOR. AND AT
THIS TIME IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE CAN QUEUE ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS ON THE
TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AT FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF A. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH THE-
BLIND NUMBER AND PUT IT BACK IN
THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE-
NOW. AND AT THIS TIME OF YEAR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. RIGHT
WE THINK IT'S FOR AN OPPOSITION
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
AID COMMISSION ESTIMATES
REVISING THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM
WILL CREATE ONGOING AND ONE
TIME GENERAL CAN COST UP TO
EIGHTY TWO POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS AND FIFTY SEVEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
RESPECTIVELY. TO SUPPORT NEWLY
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS AND TO ENABLE
EXISTING CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS
TO RETAIN THEIR AWARDS DURING
THE PROGRAM'S TRANSITION.
HOWEVER FINANCE WE WOULD
ESTIMATE THAT THE ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS TO BE
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS ABOVE THE CURRENT
APPROPRIATION LEVELS. BECAUSE
THE COMMISSION'S ESTIMATE USES.
THE DIFFER FROM CURRENT
PREPARATION LEVELS IT SEEMS
ONGOING GENERAL SUPPORT FOR THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM INCREASES BY
FIVE PERCENT. BETWEEN FISCAL
YEARS TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND AS SOON AS
I'M GOING JUMP IN SUPPORT FOR
THE STUDENTS WITH DEPENDENT
CHILDREN ACCESS AWARDS
INCREASED BY 9% BETWEEN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
ADDITIONALLY THE COMMISSION
ESTIMATES ON GOING IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND COSTS TO TREAT OR
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS RESPECTIVELY. S.
PROGRAMS ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
INDICATES THE BILL'S
ELIMINATION OF THE CAL GRANT B.
ACCESS AWARD WILL RESULT IN
COST PRESSURES OF APPROXIMATELY
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
REPLACE NON TUITION ASSISTANCE
AT CSU STUDENTS OTHERWISE WOULD
HAVE RECEIVED UNDER THE CAL
GRANT ME ACCESS AWARD INCLUDING
NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT ELIGIBLE NEW CSU
STUDENTS RESULTING FROM
ESTIMATED ENROLLMENT INCREASES.
HOWEVER IT IS UNCLEAR THESE
COST PRESSURES TO BE A BY
ENABLING MORE CS USED. FOR
CALLING GRAND HOTEL REWARD.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE INDICATES
THE BILL RESULTS IN MINOR
ANSWERABLE COSTS BUT KNOWS THAT
IT COULD RESULT IN PRO RATED
STUDENT SUCCESS COMPLETION
GRANT AWARDS. SH THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA TO GET THIS BILL
RESULTS IN MINOR SEVERAL COSTS.
AND FINALLY WE KNOW THAT THE
SPELLING QUIZ INTENT LANGUAGE
TO ENACT ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURES EXPANSIONS EXCUSE
ME THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM IN THE
FUTURE RESULTING IN SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES.
THAT ARE LOW. THE DOLLARS THANK
YOU THANK YOU WE'VE HEARD FOR
FINANCING OF QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE THAT
CONCLUDES OUR CALENDAR WE HAVE
NOTHING ON CALL- THANK YOU ALL
FOR PARTICIPATING IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT WE WANT TO
INCLUDE THEM IN THE OFFICIAL
RECORD THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU EVERYONE WHO IS HERE
FOR YOUR COOPERATION WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE GENDER THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
ADJOURN.